J in the synopsis for manson family
vacation it says it's a story about
feeling lost in society in our families
as well as in our jobs yeah can you
touch on how this is so for the
character of Conrad as well as for nick
morgan who seems to have sort of the
perfect life how is he lost in society
yeah it's I think you know at first it's
very clear that Conrad the adopted
brother that Lynn is Phillips is going
to play is the lost guy you know he's
he's pretty much borderline homeless
right now and he's just searching for
something and in the back of his mind
this there's a Manson connection
something about the Manson Family is
drawing him forward and that that's you
know he's a wayward soul and that's
pretty obvious but I think what's
special about the movie is his brought
his brother who I play Nick who's a
lawyer lives in Los Angeles his life is
very on the rails seems to have it all
together but you know you start to
realize throughout the movie that he's
really lost too and and and that you
know in today's day and age where
families are broken up and people live
in different cities you know there's
people tend to undervalue the importance
of family and the importance of
maintaining those connections and and
fighting for those connections as
difficult as they may be there it's hard
to describe and articulate perfectly but
there's something magical and emotional
and spiritual about about keeping people
together that that prevents you know
drastic moves like terrorism joining the
Manson Family you know it really glues
people together and holds them to what
really matters
you